[Music]
on today's show we talked to a mom whose
son met a girl on the internet and he's
in desperate need of some boundaries we
also talked to a husband who switched
roles during the pandemic and he's now
taking on all the domestic duties and we
talked to a woman who asked the question
does therapy really work stay tuned
[Music]
hey hey what's up this is john with the
dr john deloney show
hope you're doing well in the new year
you're being kind figuring it out
we're recording this
before the omnicron
it's not omnichrome it's omicron omicron
oh i thought it sounded like a
transformer omicron's not near as cool
it sounded cooler when i was training
whatever so i don't know where we're
gonna be in a month from now but i hope
you and your family are safe and y'all
are taking care of business and y'all
are being okay and you're being nice to
people around you being kind
hey james
booked is in it's in no more no more
touching it it then i said that in the
worst possible way
no more editing it
you know how many times we've heard that
i know
i know
i'm just gonna keep saying it out loud
into the ether so we can't just call it
good congratulations thanks man did you
work out this morning nope
no where did that come from what'd you
do instead
i woke up late
at about
10
at noon it's thought that you had to be
in compton soon
no
no easy e still too early how about this
let's go to annie in austin texas let's
just go right there what's up annie how
are we doing
good morning i'm doing good how are you
doing thank you for being here
doing good too thank you for calling so
what's up in your part of the world
yeah so well i was introduced to you by
my adult daughter who followed you she's
been a d ramsay
follower for a while and
got her finances and all straightened up
to him and i think she came to know you
through that and introduced me but
anyway getting down to the point hey
you've got a wise brilliant daughter you
raised her well way to go
thank you
so what's up
with help from people like y'all
but uh yeah i have a 17 year old son a
high school senior
um has been doing well up until summer
break uh was actually a top 10
student but then during the summer
he met a girl online from out of town a
14 year old
young girl and
could not get distracted any bad that he
is
um
and
we he told us after
three four months of talking to her and
then i could just see him
constantly we take away his phone for
night but during the day he's
i mean that he can't get away from his
phone
just completely take nowhere with this
girl
and
it was very hard he doesn't understand
he thinks that you can't
really you guys can't really understand
how it feels what it means
and to a point like
she's talking to him about you know
getting married and having kids
and he's like
it's been hard we talked to him just
stay focused on school and graduate and
get yourself a curious and become 21.
at that moment it seems like he gets it
but then pretty soon you know i think
being in touch with her we took a big
phone
set some limits
but
so it's been going on for a couple of
months now
his dad doesn't look very
actively involved in his life he's a
good guy but he isn't the kind of guy
that for a teenager
and
i feel sometimes so helpless but yeah so
there's debt there's debt a couple
questions so does dad live at home
yes okay so you all are still together
we
live separate lives but you went to the
same move um okay i mean like we run the
household but
um yeah but um so
let me excuse and how old is this young
lady
oh she's 16
and
so whoa
yeah she's 16
until when i how do you know that she's
16
well she told me and my son told me and
i mean how do you know she's 16
well
she is a sophomore in high school and my
son told me she's 16 and i had a chance
to talk to her
she didn't answer my phone and said that
i said look uh
you know we have different plans for
eating and this must stop and you should
call
if not
me and my husband planning to come over
and confront your parents because she's
sending new pictures not news but
you know her breasts and things like
that i've seen i haven't seen any from
my son and
at least he's very open and honest with
us which has been helpful he said like
he never asked her but she's been
sending
and i follow the thread and she's the
one uh you know meeting these kind of
discussions so so here here's a couple
things number one um
your
there's an old there's an old proverb
that says the best time to plant a tree
was ten years ago
yeah and this type of conversation was
best had 10 years ago but the the next
part of that proverb if i remember
correctly
is the second best time to plant a tree
is today
yeah so here's a couple things number
one your husband does not get to step
out of this conversation anymore
and it's not a flex and it's not a beat
down and it's not a this is my hou not
like that
he needs to sit down and talk to his son
about the first time he fell in love and
maybe the second and third time he fi he
needs to have some sort of conversation
with his son because his son feels like
he's on an island and he's got some
woman some young kid actually not a
woman some child
sending him nude pictures telling her
him that he is the most special thing in
his world
right and if he's growing up in a
romance-free home
of two parents who are roommates
and
um
he that type of
love that type of attraction that type
of hey you have value and let me show
you how valuable you are
they're already going to be there
because you're 17.
but and you talk about gasoline on a
fire
and here's the thing
that girl may be 12
she may be 14.
she may be she's a child
any time a child sends any sort of nude
picture
then you stop the and you know
you call parents you get them involved
and this isn't even a religious thing
this is a any human ever
i mean she is pretty i was surprised for
her uh the way she spoke to me over the
phone like she sounded older than me she
said like yeah but my daughter
my daughter told me she was over me and
she was done dealing with me and she's
five so i don't care those kind of words
i don't care about that
um i don't care what she sounds like
more importantly is your son is in
desperate need of adults in his life and
he doesn't have them
he's got an absentee buddy in dad
and he's got a
you're kind of acting like a 17 year old
almost like a sister like hey we're
going to come over there and confront
you like like west side story all going
to start snapping and walk across the
middle street together and the music's
going to play like he needs adults
and
one is the relationship part where dad
says hey man this is what it's like
falling in love you should have been
having those conversations a decade ago
clearly dad didn't so here we are today
here's what this looks like here's what
heartbreak feels like here's what making
good choices feels like
um
and then there's the
legal ethical
if your child is putting nude photos of
himself out into the world don't want to
break anybody's heart but he's not the
only one and
some adult in the world has to call the
flag or throw a flag on that one and get
with the other adults in the world
right yeah
and you guys have set boundaries and all
that my fear is this young lady is 14.
yeah and now your son's a felon
well we didn't warn him about that i
don't care yeah but he's 17 year old guy
and they
and a young woman is a young lady is
sending him pictures
you can't that's not a conversation with
a 17 year old like well you know you
need to make good choices no
every part of their brain has been taken
over that's where they need adults in
their life to step in and say i'm
stopping this
yeah you know what i mean
right
um
we know what helped i mean like it's
been ongoing for a couple of days a
couple months
finally last week
or a christian so
we my husband at least this was a good
aspect he said we're going to fast and
pray we're going to look at the word of
the lord we talked about the story of
samson and about the prodigal son and
the choices that they made
and
so he really that really hit him the
story of particles and he said well i
was at the point of wanting to go
leave you guys and go because that's how
it attracted him but so to to use that
story i think you're missing the point
of that story
okay the point of the prodigal son is
not that the boy went home ran away and
acted like an idiot
the point of that story is dad never
gave up
right and dad never stopped loving him
and dad went to the ends of the earth to
go get him
dad met him at the front of that road
yeah and what your son needs isn't a
bible story or a lecture he needs debt i
mean all those things are fine and good
he needs a dad to sit with him and say
this is what love is this is what a
felony is this is what destroying your
life and some other young child's life
is he needs a mom and a dad to get in a
car together and drive over and meet
with his parents
yeah he needs that
i think we need to do something more
aggressive like you said
it doesn't have to be aggressive
it has to be intentional
right
i'm not talking about setting things on
fire i'm not talking about starting
fights i'm talking about saying i will
go to the ends of the earth to love you
i will conti and you're a child
you're not allowed to buy cigarettes
you're not allowed to go to war you're
not allowed to buy guns not buy beer
you're a child
and you're in a relationship that is now
turned into a pornographic relationship
with another child
and we're getting in the middle of it
yeah you hear what i'm saying
you know what he said once he said mom i
have this boy in my classmate he has a
daughter and he seems happy
i'm like
what was your response
i was like you don't know what's going
on behind the doors he may be
uh you know
showing to be happy that may not be the
case behind the doors in their house you
never know what's going on in his life
but that's never he's a child and he has
a child how would that work right
your son
hear this your son is screaming out for
a connection
with anybody
i'm not ever going to fault the 17 year
old for getting infatuated with
some girl or some boy i'm never gonna
get upset with that that's the way
they're wired
i only get frustrated with parents who
don't step in and protect their children
from themselves because that's what
parents do they do boundaries they do
directness
they get involved
get involved annie get involved today
contact the other kids parents and
anybody out there listening if your kids
getting nude photos from another child
you gotta turn the lights on that deal
[Music]
you got it
i'm just telling you man i've been too
many meetings with too many people too
many investigations with too many it
just gets messy
i'm telling you get involved with that
nonsense ah they're just kids no
because when it's on the internets it's
forever
when it's on your phone it's forever
get involved you gotta get involved
danny we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapist if you
reach out to them you will be talking to
somebody within 48 hours dr john
deloney's show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right what's up we are back let's go
to rhett in temple florida
rahat what's up brother
hey how you doing good how are you
i'm doing okay doing okay good deal man
so what's up
well um
through the pandemic my my wife and i
kind of switched roles uh prior to the
pandemic i was working full time in an
office she was a stay-at-home mom
full-time
now i'm working from home full-time and
she's gone into work in an office so
i've got i've got a kid with me at home
during the day
i'm the one running the kids back and
forth between school and doing the
majority of the housework and
for both of us we're just kind of
drowning at the moment and we're not
really sure
how to make it through
man
so a
uh
good for y'all when you say you're
drowning good for you in saying hey this
is our new reality for this season so
good for you man i know it's hard and it
sounds like you all have been sprinting
for the last 24 months picking it up and
figuring out as you go
when you say you're drowning what does
that mean
tell me more about that well well you
know i've got i've got a a a fairly
demanding full-time job i've got a kid
with still got a kid with me at home how
old are you my wife what was that how
old your kid
the the youngest one is four and we have
four others that are in school okay
so um then i go get the kids at the end
of the day and then i'm trying to do
homework and i'm trying to make dinner
while my wife is still at work and then
i'm still trying to deal with the end of
the day and then
we don't have time to sit with the kids
and and and like help them with homework
or just play with them and if there's
just there's so much going on the house
is a complete wreck at the moment yeah
um
i just feel like we've got 100 things we
need to do in a day and we get to maybe
60 of them and then the next day we've
got 140 and we get to maybe six of which
just keeps on piling up and piling up
and piling up and
that's a great picture man that that's a
that's a great picture
so
back out for a second why why are you
and your wife both working full-time
jobs y'all need that financially y'all
struggling
yeah we do right now we've uh we've made
some financial mistakes the last few
years and we're trying to recover from
them okay
um
what does
here's the reality of where you are you
can't keep going like this and you're at
a natural
decision point which i love you're at
the new year you're at um you you know
you're you're
uh we're recording this just before
christmas so the year's about to roll
over people will be listening to this in
the new year so this is a moment when
you can say okay
let's let's break up the world in
semesters this was the fall semester
and
we ran real hard and we
got to the end of this race this
semester with no tread left on the tires
we can't do this so what's the spring
gonna look like
and
you've made some you've boxed yourself
into a corner with some decisions being
a we have to make this kind of money
right now in this season
b
um
i ha things have to look this way so i
want to i want to reverse engineer that
and back out of it pull the thread on
the half twos and say
what are the actual real have to things
so what's your combined income
we're making about well 150. 150
combined
yeah great so when you say you've made
some mistakes are you in the hole
financially you owe a lot you have a lot
of debt
yeah we've been walking through the dave
ramsey plan um okay well in addition to
the
in addition to the mistakes we've made
we have uh several special needs kids
that have
um services that cost
an astounding amount of money yeah it's
really really expensive
um
what does help look like for you
help for us would be
having somebody that could come in and
help us keep the house clean on occasion
um the ability to hire somebody which we
can't really afford
so it would be here's what i'm gonna
tell you every time you have a solution
for help you have a but we can't do that
and what i'm telling you is what you're
doing now you can't keep doing so at
some point something has to give
meaning we're gonna have to slow down on
our debt repayment
or we're gonna have to stop doing one of
the services for one of our kids for a
season or i'm gonna have to let my
grad school go
so that i can get some help around the
house with a house cleaner for a season
or i'm gonna have to let this full-time
job go we're gonna have to go down to 75
000 a year to make our bills and we're
gonna i'm gonna have to go to grad
school full-time right like we're at
that moment because here's where this
ends somebody gets up and walks out
yeah
or
you end up in a situation with somebody
you shouldn't be in or your wife ends up
somebody will talk to her you know what
i'm saying like this is this is that
season where things start getting messy
are you all already there by the way
well we're not there but i can feel us
getting close to getting real close
that's right
so
what can give
surely you can make your minimum
payments on things with 150 000 a year
well um
[Music]
i mean we
we we had we sold one of the cars we've
we've cut back on streaming services um
we can probably eat out a little bit
less
we're going through step two
we really we feel like we've streamlined
as much as we can
much money do you owe
we owe about two hundred thousand
and what's the debt
uh we have um
lots of credit cards student loans and
then
some loans that we took out to try to
consolidate things
that didn't manage it properly
okay
so the good news is the bad news is you
got a big hole and you've heard me say
this before on other shows the good news
is you got a big shovel you'll make 150
grand
okay
the tough news is you got four little
kids two with special needs is that you
said what are their special needs
uh one of them is autistic and the other
one has the severe speech impediment
okay so you got one in speech
therapy and you got one with like an aba
specialist of some sort
yeah okay and that's incredibly
expensive how many of that those
resources can be taken care of with this
local school district
none
why not
they they just don't cover it they they
they offer some
help like service like you can go and
meet with a counselor during the day but
like they don't have aba services they
have some speech therapy but it's not
been
it it's not been successful
it's like a group therapy once a week
i don't know that that's accurate um i i
i i'm certain that that's what i told
you
there may be depending on your state
there may be some legal responsibilities
that they have to provide these services
um and there's disability rights
organizations that will help families
like yours
go to bat with school districts who say
well we just don't help that kind of kid
okay um there's some there's some legal
so i want you to check out your
disability rights
um
office for your state um i partnered
with i was on the board of one in texas
and they go help students who have needs
that school districts say yeah we're
just not gonna do that i don't know that
the school district has the legal rights
to do that
um okay and that might save you an
astounding amount of money that you
already pay in tax dollars
um here's what has to happen okay
is you and your wife
gotta get away and you'll have to take a
full inventory of the world right now
because your world is not sustainable
and you're gonna crash
and you think world life is expensive
now wait till you go through divorce
court that's when it gets real expensive
and
something has to give
whether i've got to stop doing school
for a season i've been there i had to do
it my wife had to do it we had to take
semesters off during grad school
multiple times because because our
season was
bonkers um you may have to ask your boss
for a different schedule or you may have
to hire a some sort of part-time nanny
or a babysitter who also helps clean the
house a couple times a week to give you
relief
and that may mean slowing down your baby
step two your your sprint to pay off
your debt
just so you can survive
but running a marathon man running a
marathon and not stopping to drink water
to get a better time is a good idea
until you collapse at mile 17 and you
don't finish
you just got a series of hard realities
man you got to pick your poison on them
yeah
is there when you say like
we're drowning we're not making it
is it a matter of if i got up 30 minutes
early and just got the laundry knocked
out my wife and i just did a blitzkrieg
on the house 30 minutes and then when
she got home
she took over kids and we i took over
dinner i mean is there some ways that we
can do this one of the challenges i've
seen over the last 24 months with work
from home is work becomes always
yeah and there's no time to say i am
officially off now now i am changing
hats and i am now being a dad i'm not
being a i'm not making dinner i'm now
whatever or how much of your challenge
right now is because you resent the fact
that you're having to do quote unquote
domestic work
while she's in the office
how much is this is is role reversal
i don't know there's as much role
reversal in that um
she she has gone through a series of
uh low depressive type periods over the
last two years
so when she comes home she just doesn't
feel like doing much
and i mean i grew up in a household
where my father would stay at home so i
was modeled okay cool domestic work so
like it doesn't bother me to have to do
it it's just that i'm doing everything
95 percent of it yeah so
what work is your wife doing to to
lean into her depression
not much
okay that's god
i've talked to her about counseling
she's not really interested
do you have any reason why she's any
idea why she's making that choice
uh
she just goes into michelle sometimes
i don't know why
okay
you know this i'm just saying this out
loud your marriage is in big trouble i
can hear it in you
is that fair
yeah
and
i absolutely
understand have seen i've walked
alongside countless depressions real and
so is a choice to heal
a choice to lean into
different ways of being
and
that has to be a part of moving forward
here's the sucky part you can't make her
do that you can only control you
so here's my recommendation for you
i want you to sit down with her and say
we're going to look at this budget
and we're going to look at our world
because i have to get some help around
here
period
and you can choose to help lean into
some of that and i actually think that
would help some of the depressive stuff
is
having some roles and tasks around the
house that are little wins
um and are provide purpose and
contribution
um
but she may not be willing to do that so
i then i've got to hire somebody to come
over and clean the house and help pick
up and i've got to hire a babysitter at
least a couple of days a week to help
with child care because i can't get my
job done
and i want you to start seeing somebody
okay
um
i want you to make a commitment to start
seeing somebody so i'm going to do this
for you i'm going to give you a year's
supply i mean a year's subscription to
ramsey plus
okay okay that is that's the every
dollar app that's super fancy and
expensive it's when me and my wife use
it is a year's subscription to all the
lessons with financial peace but here's
what the financial p stuff does you know
this but it is also i think in a
remarkable depression tool
it's a remarkable anxiety tool because
it gives people a series of small steps
to work towards
yeah okay so i'm gonna give it to you i
want you all to commit to watching all
those lessons if you've already done i
want you to do it again
okay
and at some point you're gonna have to
spend some money that you feel like you
don't have
you're gonna have to
pay off a little bit less debt because
you my friend need to go talk to
somebody because you are all you can
control and you're about to cash out of
the fa i can hear it in you you're
almost
done i'm getting there yes
and she does too and maybe you're
modeling it will provide a path forward
for what this may look like
that'd be great
and it may be that um you go with our
partners with better help and go to
betterhelp.com and you get a discount on
that one and you can do counseling from
home with headphones and a screen and
talk to somebody while your kid is
asleep and that way you don't even have
to leave the house
or it may be great for you to get out of
that house for a minute
and drive and be around other adults and
sit in somebody else's place and just
have that conversation right
um
yeah
but you're worth it your marriage is
worth it she's worth it the kids are
worth it
here's the meta here for you and for
anybody listening
we get trapped in these things we box
ourselves into these corners and you've
done a number you owe two hundred
thousand dollars that's a lot of debt
with four young kids two of with who
have special needs
there is a harsh math reality to your
world that's a lot of money
it may mean that you sell the house and
you rent for a season
it may mean that you go down to one car
and you since you're working at home you
have no car it may mean that you have
zero streaming services until this
thing's clean who knows you may have to
get pretty spartan
it may mean that you got to go call the
school district or get with the
disability rights organization in your
community in your state and go to war
with the school district and say y'all
have to do your federal responsibility
and help my kids out with these services
you don't just get to pick and choose
which disability services you support
and which ones you don't that's not how
that's not how the ada 504 rules laws
work
it may mean that you got to go to
council whatever that looks like
but the way things are working are not
working
so the only option you have is to drown
intentionally or to do something
different
and the best way to do something
different is to get off-site you heard
me say this a thousand times i'll say it
a thousand times more get off-site with
your wife and create plan
b
plan a didn't work so we have to do plan
b what's that going to look like and how
we're going to make this thing work
hard conversations and intentional
conversations you can do them my brother
we'll be right back with the dr john
delany's show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's do one more let's go to
alicia in
philadelphia where i was born and raised
the playgrounds where i spent most of my
days how are we doing
hey how's it going hey good how are you
i'm doing pretty good can't complain yes
you could you'd be like everybody else
but you're not and that's so great
so good hey so what's up how can i help
i have a bit of a loaded question for
you john oh i love loaded questions do
we used to hang out when i was a kid
make just let me know that if i'm about
to get canceled
nothing i know of maybe a past life i'm
always afraid that an old friend of mine
is going to call me like i got a loaded
question for you remember that time i'll
be like well this show's over
so what's up uh
less loaded than that um so my question
is is therapy not for everyone
tell me more
so um i was diagnosed with bipolar 2
disorder when i was a freshman in
college which was about eight years ago
now okay and since then i have probably
seen seven different therapists
with really no success
i haven't found one yet that i feel
is really therapeutic and i've kind of
said to myself you know maybe it's me
maybe i'm doing something wrong so i
really switched it up
i would give each therapist anywhere
between six months to a year to give the
process the full chance that it has
i've tried different genders
of therapists i've tried different
approaches from talk therapy to cvt
i've tried different formats i've tried
online i've tried in person and i keep
finding myself in the same situation
after like the fourth or fifth session
where i just feel like i'm not really
getting anything out of it i don't have
any breakthroughs
and
i just
i don't know john i just feel like i
keep getting into the same rut
and i'm not sure if it's just my
personality isn't very conducive to the
therapy environment or maybe it's
something that i'm doing
well one
dude that's not a loaded question at all
that's a great question good for you
and number two
dude
like
the fact that you were willing to step
out and go
hey i'm looking at all of these things
and there's one common denominator it's
me maybe it's me
that's a that's a level of reflection
that many don't ever make it to so good
for you like that like that's great
um let me ask you this what are you
like why would you go to counseling
why would you go um what are you hoping
to get out of it
it's a good question um one of the
things i've tried to do with the last
two
is do exactly what i think you're asking
it's like what are the actual objectives
that you have for going
and i found that
there's kind of like three for me
um the first is dealing with any
childhood baggage that i still have that
i haven't had the chance to really go
through myself
the second is dealing with
some things that i've noticed trigger my
bipolar disorder pretty bad so whether
it be like imposter syndrome at work
or
executive dysfunction in my life and the
last um
is usually around relationships um and
how to better foster those because i
also have a lot of
difficulties with that in my life i'm a
very private person and i'm like the
mysterious friend that everyone has just
like i'm the friend that i ask thousands
of questions but i don't really answer
them myself so why
why have you chosen that identity
that's a great question i
i don't know um
it's just something that feels very
comfortable for me yeah it serves you in
some way what is it
um
less judgment for sure right you can't
be judged if people don't really know
much about you but you get to be the
judge of everybody which is awesome
yeah it really benefits me yes
um so
like can i ask you a couple of hard
questions
yeah i mean i asked you one i think
that's fair oh you asked me you gave me
a softball no that was awesome um
at this point
what childhood baggage do you not know
about
that's a good point i think
i mean i lived through it is there
anything unspoken
um in what way do you mean can you
rephrase uh did you have childhood
trauma of some sort
yeah so i had um
my father is extremely um
mentally ill he's
not only as bipolar but he also
schizophrenia so my i had a very chaotic
childhood
from just parents that didn't really
know how to
parent and also just didn't have the
mental stability to be able to do it
successfully
and you know underneath that so number
one yes that is a major
major trauma
having a chaotic childhood but
underneath that
you have a brain that never learned how
to connect with somebody else
yeah i think that's fair and
that disconnection from a person to
another person
is
the chief alarm that's going to go off
over and over and over again and then
when you start to connect then your
brain remembers oh yeah this is
dangerous we've been down this road
before and so you just get in that loop
you know what i mean i gotta connect
gotta connect we're connecting whoa we
can't do that and then we're off to the
races again
yeah is that fair sounds like me
yeah and then you go up and down toggle
up and down up and down up and down but
here's the thing i want to i want to
lean on you know that
fair
yeah i think so so
give me off the top of your head two or
three triggers immediately go
um
so the first one that's
like screaming in my mind is
feeling judged um okay
the i guess the other one
is
um
i don't know
the feeling judge one just seems so big
in my mind that it almost takes up like
two or three spots why like
i don't i i think it's something i think
one one of the things from my childhood
not only from my parents but from other
facets of my life too
um
i i've like
i just never really had a chance so like
when i was born i was born with a birth
defect so i was already like in an
outcast kind of situation and then i
grew up with parents who were super
chaotic and i was known as like the kid
in the neighborhood from like that crazy
house and um
and then as i got older i started
gaining a lot of weight i was the chubby
kid like that was an outcast um and then
as i got older than that i found out i
was gay that was an outcast so i think i
found myself like the less i tell people
about myself and my surroundings like
the less i'll be judged
so can i push on that come from yeah
the name of my new book i don't even
know if i'm allowed to say it can i say
it here's the name of the new book
my new book
it's like you're setting me up here i
i'll send you i'm gonna send you a free
copy it didn't come out for a few months
but you're like setting me up here
the name of the book is own your past
change your future
and here's where most mental health
practitioners get stuck and more
importantly here's where most
mental health
clients can get stuck
is you know your past
those things happened
they are real
and then what is next
is up to you
and it sounds to me like
you have made an identity out of what
happened in the past and that identity
prohibits you from living a rambunctious
joyful exciting adventurous life
and every day is some sort of reckoning
or trying to reconcile a past that can't
be reconciled it just is and there's a
period at the end of that sentence
and it sounds like you spent the last
eight nine 10 20 years trying to go back
and edit that sentence that can't be
edited instead of using that energy to
write something new
hear what i'm saying
yeah i hear what you're saying and so as
somebody who's got my own triggers for a
number of things
the key to moving forward in your life
is leaning into the triggers until they
don't trigger you anymore not running
from them
so the key if you have a traumatic abuse
of childhood
is
i think the the the name of the book
seeking safety finding safety
you work with a counselor for 12 to 16
sessions
or that's what the whole maps thing with
uh it's like whatever the
path you take the goal is i can think
about those things that happen to me i
can remember them and my body doesn't
take off on me
that's the choice to heal
that you could say man i was judged and
i was abused i was neglected i grew up
in a chaotic home i don't even have a
picture of what love looks like
and
i'm gonna go find it
and i am worth being loved and i'm worth
laughing and i'm worth having an
adventure and i'm worth people finding
out all of me
and still loving me anyway
that's where it becomes a choice
tomorrow becomes a choice today becomes
a choice the past you can't it is
so my question for you is
i think if you go to a therapist to get
the magic sentence that's going to go ah
that's it like the good will hunting
moment record he's like it's not your
fault and you hug and he's like oh and
i'm going to go
i'm going to go see about a girl it's
my one my favorite movies of all time
that's not how therapy usually works
it sounds what you need is somebody to
hold you accountable to a as you
practice a new identity
and the identity would be i am worthy of
being loved and you know what practice
is someone holding you accountable
accountable is a fancy word for judge
oh boy
you're gonna have to get a counselor or
a therapist or a psychologist or a
friend or a mentor or a coach somebody
who will sit with you and you say
i'm gonna start treating my body right
and that will look like on most days i'm
going to eat well and i'm going to
exercise come hell or high water i'm
taking care of my body
i am going to journal my negative
thoughts
i'm going to write them down and i'm
going to email them to you every day and
if i don't you're going to call me which
is a form of judgment and then your
trigger you're going to trigger and
you're going to either go
way up or way down and you're going to
have to say no i'm going to be in the
middle of this are you still taking your
medication
yes i am okay so i'm gonna continue to
take care of take my meds i'm gonna
continue to do the things that are gonna
help me be well but here's what i want
you to hear
you're practicing this new stuff because
you've never done it before
and this is
much more about
physical practice than it is cognitive
practice i think you've cognitively
practiced yourself into the ground is
that fair
yeah i think so do you think a lot
sounds like you've thought a lot for the
last 10 years
yeah i think i'm like i'm a very very i
think you've also noticed i'm a very
reflective person yes
but you spend so much time in reflection
that you're letting every day go by
underneath you
yeah
like you're driving forward by looking
in the rearview mirror
and i'd love for you to look out the
windshield that's so much bigger
there's so much awesome stuff ahead of
you if you will let yourself be loved
and that means you have to let yourself
have risk and that means you have to let
yourself get hurt again
and that to answer your original
question is what a counselor can do
many people don't know why they feel the
way they feel i think you know
what a counselor could help you do
or a friend or a coach right could help
you then say okay
what happens next i want to practice
what happens next
and here's the here's the simple
like the simple truth and this is
ancient and this is neuroscience it's
everything in between
here's the three things you can control
you can get connected to a group of
people that care about you and love you
that could be one person that could be
five people
you can change your thoughts and you can
change your actions and that's it
how does that sound
it sounds doable
i mean i i think um i'm i'm down for
anything right like i'm at a point where
i know something's got to give i just
don't really know what has to give okay
so i think you i think you've given me a
bit of a clear path of what that could
look like i would love you to give
council one more try
and i want you to set a series of
identity goals
and this comes from james clear stuff
it's
i think it's one of the wisest
sentiments i've heard in the last decade
here's what it is when you're going to
change your life you're going to change
your behaviors change your actions
change your habits whatever that looks
like
start with who i want to be
and then reverse engineer it because
most of us start with i want to lose 20
pounds
i want to start dating i want to go on
four dates this month i want we we set
these arbitrary numerical goals
and man we can all grit our teeth and
and grind out 10 pounds
but it just comes right back because
we're the same person
the way to do this sustainably is to say
i'm the kind of person
who's a steward of their body
i'm the kind of person who's the steward
of their mind
i take care of my brain what does that
mean that's going to impact what i watch
how much i sleep
um not scrolling the internet 24 7.
taking a class at the local library for
free on how to knit or tile a bathroom
count i mean whatever it's going to be
i'm going to invest in myself i'm a guy
who goes who says yes and goes on
adventures that's the one for me because
i have a tendency to get exhausted and
turn into a recluse
and one of my core identities is i will
say yes to adventures i ended up on an
adventure this weekend alicia
dude
dude it was bananas and when i got home
i was so glad i did it my son on the way
home he was like dad can you believe we
just did that i was like nope but we did
right
um it made no sense like
like physically my sleep none of it made
sense and it was awesome and we will
talk about that story for years so i say
yes because if i just said i need to do
three things i wouldn't do it but i'm a
guy who does those things so now i'm
gonna end up in that space so i want you
to come up with three to five identities
here's who i'm gonna be
and then i want you to take that to a
counselor and say i need to build a
plan that you will help hold me
accountable to
and we're not focusing on the past as
much anymore because you know
now we're focusing on moving forward and
you
have to become okay with being in a
relationship with someone who can hold
you accountable that's life
sounds like a plan john
do you promise
no yeah seriously i will will you write
me back and say you're full of crap do
it in your one of your low seasons like
i
getting a look get a load letter from
somebody with bipolar is one of the most
harrowing yet awesome things because it
is so caustic and after you read it
you're like oh oh my
and then a few weeks later you talked to
him like i didn't mean that and then
you're like wait what what
so you wait
you know what i'm talking about you sent
those right
me no never
yes i love it
so
you promise you a
how about this here's here's the thing
just for the listener i want you to
write down your five identities and i
want you to email them to me
i'm gonna read them on the internets
we're all gonna hold you accountable
your game all right
i'm game yeah let's do it all right and
then you're gonna go find one more
you're gonna give it one more shot
and you're gonna say i want to become
this person and that means i need some
help with my nutrition i need some help
with exercise help with my mental health
help and
partners in a pear tree and we're gonna
make this thing happen you in
i'm yeah i'm totally in this is my next
adventure this is the next adventure why
because you're a person who goes on
adventures can that be one
yeah
and what if one of them was you're a
person who doesn't mind being judged
what is
then people would say why'd you wear
that and you could then go i don't know
because i like it or you could go yeah
that was dumb i won't wear that anymore
and then you just brush your shoulders
off and move on about your day because
it doesn't mean you're not a great
awesome wonderful person
is that pretty ideal yeah it's not ideal
it's just reality so we're just gonna
choose that and we're gonna practice it
and then we start when someone says oh
my gosh
why are you dating that person
then your heart takes off on you and you
start to go
then you just get curious and go why is
my body taken oh
judger i'm a person who doesn't mind
being judged cool thanks for sharing
thank you idiot fair
yes be curious be curious and
change your identities
get connected
change your thoughts change your actions
freedom
can we do that can we be braveheart here
for a second alicia now you're solving
for freedom you're awesome all right as
we wrap up today's show song of the day
dude we're going old school 1992 one of
my favorite hardcore records of all time
sick of it all this song is locomotive
and it goes like this hey this is a song
for alicia
yes look at that serendipitous trapped
in a rut and i can't get out don't see a
way to be free working it every day
nothing i do or say can break my poverty
my desperate eyes will close tonight i
hope i won't feel a thing because i know
tomorrow i'll continue with my sorrow
and my desperate eyes will sting
no matter how we try no matter how we
strive we just can't seem to get ahead
but day in day out feeling the grind
some way somehow gonna leave it behind
day in day out feeling the grind
some way somehow going to leave it
behind
i'll tell you how you're going to you're
going to get connected you're going to
change your thoughts you're going to
change the things that you do and you're
going to solve for freedom and you're
going to heal
and it's going to be awesome alicia
we're all rooting for you right here on
the dr john dolone show